for the tampa bay rays it's going to be
their big right-hander tyler glass now
making his 11th start of the season era
2.90 the 87 strikeouts we talked about
in the open that is good for fourth in
major league baseball
done all of that in 62 innings of work
and tyler glass now all set to go to
work here against what mary field and
there's a swing and a miss comes back
with that breaker nicely done yeah you
you could see that one coming after he
spiked that first like wait a minute
wait a minute let me get this thing
right look how long that stays in the
zone right about thigh high
and by the time that the swing is
complete that ball right down there on
the dirt merrifield empty andrew ben and
tindy
shoots it into left center field
phillips on the run on the run on the
red and he got there
phillips runs it down in left center
field great acceleration by brett
phillips and the backhanded grab boy
stamp that one with a star as the royals
send left-hander mike miner to the mound
so let's see how he does today he's got
to mix them up and keep him down use the
defense yandy diaz oh speed pitches up
and a 2-2 count
good movement on a change-up that pitch
got knocked around in miner's last start
but he threw a beauty to diaz and there
are two down blue kc pitch tracks to
show you the movement on that changeup
away from the right hander that's
exactly what that pitch is designed to
do excellent job austin meadows with two
down he played in left field last night
he's the dh tonight
high fastball meadows strikes out minor
strikes out two
and down go the raise in order in the
first brandon lau three and two
and a strikeout and that's miners third
against the last four batters joey
wendell lefty lefty matchup
fastball mike miner has struck out four
already they're two down in the second
inning he blew it by him at 92. he's so
good with his off-speed pitches mike
miner is that he gets the hitter
thinking that he's gonna get a breaking
ball and then it's by the time he sees
it's too late to react two on two out to
mike zanino who is a strikeout candidate
and zanino strikes out so minor gets
away with a couple of mistakes and then
strikes out zanino with a breaking ball
and miner strikes out three in the
second monday leading off the third
obviously out on strikes strikeout
number three dyson chops it toward the
middle
this is wendell and they got it
joey wendell playing shortstop tonight
that is not an easy play listen dwayne
dyson runs i i mean is there anybody
faster in the game not many if there is
look how quickly he's got to get rid of
it and look how close it is love and
fire and how about diaz two-and-one to
count to nicki lopez
ground ball
he has to glass now nice play down
well some good defense here on display
now joey wendell
there you go santana dives and miner
gets to the bag one step in front of
wendell i thought that was gonna be a
double play ball but he he put that
pretty good spot nice play by santana
and carlos is going to talk to nikki
lopez they're having a conversation
right now why to first and they might
carlos might be asking nikki should i
have let that go to you exactly and
typically you know now that nikki's back
over there again there'll be a
conversation even a reminder in game as
nikki lopez holler at santana and saying
hey anything soft hit i got it i'm over
here well we have another situation here
in the fourth for mike zanino
two outs rosso's at second
that's a liner of the base hit into left
browser's going to turn third the throw
will not be in time and the raise takes
the lead
scores from second as zenino comes
through to make it want nothing well
here it is dwayne
this ball just kind of stays middle in
mike zenino it's up around the belt
and he's able to fire on it right there
light it get it into the hole and then
here comes mike grosso
that throw by ben attendee he gives a
good effort but brazo too quick
raves take the lead zenino is fired up
and it's about time and bat with diaz
two and two
[Applause]
down goes yandy diaz
meadows takes his time digging back in
against the white line
deep in the batter's box
fastball struck him out rose arena
started to run and stopped and that was
a good choice because that would have
been a strikeout throw out double play
would have been great beautiful spot
right on the outside where salvi was
sitting mike miner he looks good margot
has an infield single and he's grounded
out to first
rosarina runs and he is out oh beautiful
throw man how about that pop time from
the time salvador perez catches it in
his glove till the time the ball gets
down there to second base to the
fielder's glove 1.8 seconds he's one of
the best a good time is 2-0
lopez
strikeouts in this game for tyler glass
now
and make it 10. breaking ball in the
dirt ceno down to first to lopez is out
2-3 to complete the strikeout on the
breaking ball and that's ten strikeouts
for glass now well he went back to that
curveball how about that he gets the
swing on the breaking ball
that bounces in front of the plate
that's how deceptive that pitch can be
just now with 98 pitches so far there's
a 2-2 runner goes swinging in a miss
fastball
you've fired that one right by him
santana is out of there on strikes
he is not going to get the opportunity
to close this one out but i'll tell you
he did his job well eight innings
of shutout baseball for tyler glass now
we've got jp firerison taking them out
here to try to finish this one off see
if benny can start it off just get on
base base runner
hit left field not good
it is go
catch that one benintendi finally got it
to a spot
where there was no center fielder this
young man can go to opposite field yeah
he says catch that one they've been
robbing him twice
in this series here and there was the
first off speed pitch and it's really a
fat change up right in the middle he got
it you could tell right on contact he's
saying that ball had some good carry
plus he got some backspin on it cash in
the other dugout going
tyler walls can handle the bat the young
infielder kansas city expecting the bunt
and nobod a high fly ball backhand at
deep center dyn will look up and make
the catch on the track attack kirby's
going to go to third well
it's a sacrifice but it gets the runner
over and that's the main thing that's
the bottom line taylor walls put a very
good swing on that hanging change up by
zuber gave it a ride
it's going to end up a little bit short
but
that's going to get kiermeier over to
third he was actually rounding third
thinking maybe if something went awry
and walls getting some congratulations
by all of his teammates
so with kiermeier at third meadows dude
they're going to send him to first base
they'll wave him down there on the
intentional pass and well margot is
going to be the hitter and a ground ball
in the right
base hit ray's win
crosses the plate manuel margot right
through the open right side of the
infield between first and second and the
rays win this would intend
it's a two-to-one final